france starts to lift its quarantine
churches and mosques have opened their
doors to worshippers for the first time
in two months
and with the weather getting warmer
people across france have flocked
outside to enjoy the sun
this week is expected to be critical in
determining whether now really is the
right time to be lifting the lockdown
charlotte dubensky in paris looks at how
life has changed
since the measures were eased france is
expecting to get its first sense
this week as to whether the
deconfinement measures
are working it's now two weeks since the
lockdown started to be
eased here across the country
hospital admissions have generally been
falling day on day
and we know that there are fewer
patients now in intensive care than they
were
two weeks ago but as the weather is
getting better and particularly
given that we've just had a weekend
following a bank holiday here in france
there were fears that there could be a
lot of people
out in the streets in places like here
next to the sen
where there could be further
transmission of the disease people were
being urged to
stay at home or if they do come out to
socially distance to stay away from
other people to respect those barrier
distances
now parks here in paris are still closed
and
as you can see here along the sun there
is fencing
in places this fencing to try and
discourage
people from coming to sit in the nice
grassier areas
here at the sen now i was out at the
weekend
and while there were crowds of people
out it wasn't as packed
as many people feared and there were
more patrols
taking place by the police too to make
sure that people were socially
distancing
but is there a fear of that second wave
here in france
this is what people tell me
social distancing is respected more or
less
but i think that there are lots of
people who think the virus won't affect
them
personally i'm not afraid but i i can
see that people still are respecting the
distance and stuff so
i'm pretty confident i don't think
anything is going to happen
we have completely overcome this it's
difficult to say
but in fact i think this was done by
some higher power
if the second wave is supposed to happen
it will happen
and unfortunately we can't do anything
about it
i work at the hospital i'm used to
wearing masks
and i think that everybody should wear
them i don't want to believe in the
second wave
because i don't want to experience this
life again and i think
people should be careful well calm here
in paris at least but that wasn't the
case elsewhere in france
in the commune of san azar which is just
west to the city
of nantes on the west coast of france
there were protests with people
unhappy with the restrictions that are
still in place following
the start of deconfinement the police
came
out and they used tear gas
thank you
[Music]
there was though announcements from the
government of
more easings of restrictions the council
of state had told the government
that it was not allowed to restrict
religious services
and now that means after many many weeks
religious services have started back up
again
here in france also a sense that we'll
get this week as to
what will happen for the summer holidays
with the french being told by one
minister that that is likely to be a
holiday
that will be only here in france
on top of that we had new measures
announced by the french government in
regards to quarantines
for those people coming to the country
from the united kingdom
that is being put in place as a
reciprocal measure
given that the uk announcement the uk
government announced something
similar just last week and finally
in another attempt to try and boost
france's ailing economy which has seen
its gdp predictions
plunge this year one minister has
announced that there will be
a 3 billion euro
freeze on social security payments for
some businesses who are affected by the
covid
19 pandemic meaning that they won't have
to make those social security payments
france this week waiting to find out now
whether those post lock down measures
are working
and whether it can extend and the easing
of the restrictions even further
charlotte dubinsky rt paris